now at first when you see the title of
this video it might sound that it's not
possible but there is this species known
as tardigrates or water bears which are
indeed capable of surviving in space in
fact tardigrades are one of the most
resistive species that are known to
exist or not they are capable of
surviving a variety of harsh conditions
such as high radiation high temperatures
and even the vacuum of space
scientists have conducted several
experiments where they've sent
tardigrants to space and they were
amazed to find that they can not only
just survive but are even capable of
reproducing in space very fascinating
isn't it if you know more such facts
about tardigrids feel free to share in
the comment section below and subscribe
to our Channel